isolation has a lot of different side
effects but there's one part of
isolation that could be totally
catastrophic
to near future but before i tell you
about isolation let me tell you a story
about what happened this week so this
past week i was running a zoom
with folks who were one the first to buy
the book and i did a raffle was ten of
them
we're sitting there doing a zoom
everybody's telling their story etcetera
etcetera one of the guys gets up he's 20
years old he says i've been following
valuetainment
since 17 years old when i was in high
school i watch all your videos he said i
watch
everything he was quoting stuff from
this video that video anyways eventually
he says i'm in vermont i'm living there
i decide to go out of high school and
become an entrepreneur he goes to
university in ohio
ghost joins our entrepreneurship program
joins a
group in school with 160 different kids
that are trying to be entrepreneurs
asks how many of you guys are
entrepreneurs none of them had a
business at that time says then why am i
in here he leaves drops that goes and
starts doing online
sales starts doing 180 000 here with his
friend
and he's in vermont in his basement the
last eight months
isolated because of where he's at you
can't get out
shut down you know don't go out
quarantine everything to be safe right
he's the only child and he starts
telling the story
and he says uh i'm not excited about
life
i said why is that i said how many
people are you around my daughter's by
the window there i'm trying to get this
video before i get out
i said how many people are you around he
said i'm not around a lot of people
i said are you isolated as he says i am
i said how do people treat you
he says they think i'm a little weird i
said they think you're weird as well he
said yes
i said you're 20 years old i said you
had a very rough age you're at an age
where you're trying to be accepted
you're trying to be approved you're
trying to get people to
uh uh see the cool side of you and
you're probably shy you've been rejected
you've had a lot of pain
and uh i just want you to know
everything's gonna be all right
i said this to him everything's gonna be
all right
he started crying for five minutes
non-stop we have the video
he started crying on stuff for five
minutes
and he's making money things are good
but he's isolated he's by himself
he needs company he needs to be around
people
he wants to be around people we need
that little tap
we need that little how you doing how's
everything you good is everything okay i
was in
san antonio yesterday for an event that
some of our leaders put together there
was 140 people in the room
i can't tell you how many people
couldn't wait to see each other at this
one resort that the guys rented
i was with them we stayed till two three
o'clock in the morning if you were
following my instagram we were listening
to rmb and
they were playing r b music to see if i
can guess it and i was playing r b music
to see if they could guess it and
i got something they couldn't get they
got some i couldn't get it was 17 of
them there was one of me i lost seven to
six
but we weren't isolated we were around
each other there's strength in numbers
there's strength in having people around
you that have bought into your vision
so if you're listening to this i just
want you to know
2020 has been a weird year one of the
biggest parts of 2020 that's been weird
is the fact that a lot of people have
been
isolated they've been forced to be
isolated
and what you've missed is that
camaraderie with another human being
that conflict with another human being
that conversation with another human
being
that that you know discourse with
another human being what do you think
about this i agree i disagree what do
you think
you're missing that because you're in
isolation and uh
you know everyone's telling you to stay
and everyone's telling you to do all
this other stuff
i'm sorry you got to go see people i'm
not telling you to go to a nightclub and
go to a bar and get a hammer with 5 000
people and be
responsible but you got to kind of get
out and go see people
even if it's a couple people even if
it's five people inlets 10 people
staying in isolations got very big side
effects long term
but there's a lot of you that are
watching this right now that live in
different parts of the world some of you
guys are in state saying pat i'm not in
isolation i can be out
some of you guys are in countries that
you are isolated you can't get out
um two messages for you if you can
by law go out and meet with people do so
number two if you can't
because you're isolated and your
imagination is going crazy thinking
crazy crazy thoughts just taper it down
and bring you down to not overreact and
make a dumb decision
i'm sincerely telling you everything's
going to be all right
everything's going to be all right it's
a motto that's changed my life
future looks bright even if it's ugly
right now
when you're patient enough it takes
three months six months 12 months 24
months
things all of a sudden change for the
better so whatever you're going through
right now this week of christmas that we
have coming up i celebrate christmas i
comfortably say merry christmas to
people
but if you don't celebrate christmas
happy holidays to you
um as you reflect
with everything that happened in 2020
just know
i promise you everything's gonna be all
right
i'm telling you everything's gonna be
all right not telling you bad things are
not gonna happen bad things are gonna
happen
but everything is still gonna be all
right and future looks bright
don't let your imagination make you
believe that armageddon's around the
corner
it's going to be fine things are going
to go in the right direction
with that being said i got a video i
want you to watch it's 12 mistakes i
made my first year as an entrepreneur if
you've never watched this click over
here
and if i don't see you or i'm around you
because you're going to be around some
friends and family
from me to you and your family merry
christmas to you
take care everybody bye-bye